i'd like to call back your memory to
this
do you remember this um we
drew the seven leaf light uh or rather
we wrote it all up based on this data
um we just went through we did the
numbers it took a bit of time because
you often get quite a lot of data for it
but then from there we noticed two
things i only showed you one of them
though
the first thing was if you turn your
graph on its side
you can actually think of this thing as
a bar graph right you don't need to
worry about all those individual numbers
all the time
sometimes you're just worried about like
where are the main groups of numbers are
they mostly the edges mostly in the
middle
whatever okay um the second thing which
some people ask me about i didn't show
on the board though because i didn't
have one ready
is that you can you don't have to go
from here to a bar graph
sometimes from your first stem and leaf
plot they might ask you
to create an ordered stem and lean plot
can you see the difference it's quite
subtle right
i'll zoom in a little bit the difference
is that when you have a look at these
numbers
oops i freeze it what did you go for
when you have a look at the numbers
i've just arranged all of these in
ascending order okay
um this is a really useful skill i think
it's most it's easiest
to put it out of order first right make
sure you haven't missed any of these
and then to put them in order this will
become really important
next week when we have a look at
quartiles and deciles and percentiles
they all to do with things that data
gets informed okay
but just rewinding a second i want to
come back to this because in this lesson
we're going to focus on
bar graphs column graphs that kind of
thing so if you haven't already could
you open up your
textbook for me
is it double-sided oh yeah
i can show you um
the short answer is you're going to do
it in exactly the same way but just
left instead of right or left as well as
right i should say
the reason you do it is if you're
comparing two groups of two groups of
people
two classes two teams like that and
you're like oh one cluster is like
really high and the other one's really
low then i can compare them
okay so your heading is um column
and bar graphs or column or bar graphs
now this is the first question in 7h i'm
doing this one
for you for free you're welcome um
column
slash
now we've already learned lots of
different ways of drawing
and showing representing what data is
like i want you to
please remember we're not just showing
you lots of these because
because we can until you have lots of
things to remember it's because
each different way of representing
something it solves a particular kind of
problem
okay so common bar graphs is very like
look
i don't want to worry about how much
time it takes to get every single
score on my center leaf plot i just need
to know the overall shape
so when you have a look at data which
it's not as finely detailed or you don't
need to worry about the fine details
that's when we go for these kinds of
things okay so what i'm going to do is
we'll do an example of this and then
i'll point out some principles that you
can remember to make sure your
graphs look really good okay so the
first thing is please get a ruler out
get a ruler out in fact i'm trying to
make a point about this so even i'm
going to get a ruler out
we're going to create a column graph for
this
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is
draw myself a set of x's
[Music]
does anyone borrow a raw i've got some
yeah please go ahead
it's um it works trust me uh it really
does
it's functional it doesn't well because
i don't have to draw them straight this
way i have to jump
straight this way which works
i see it look on your face it's
completely unconvinced
yeah i think there's going to be a
variety of errors in there it's like why
is my graph so wavy
okay now i've got my
uh nice orderly axes okay
the first thing i want to do before i
say what's going on here is i need to
decide
which axis is which okay now a column or
a bar graph
you can set it up horizontally so all of
your bars go
this way or you can set it up vertically
in some senses it doesn't really matter
but i will point out maybe you want to
drop this like near your heading or
something like that
there are two kinds of data that you
very frequently see one way or the other
and for the rest of it it's kind of like
whichever you feel like basically a lot
of data you'll see
this is not an example but a lot of that
you see is chronological okay
so for example you might see rainfall or
average temperatures or something like
that
in the months of the year okay now if
you have
data and it's ordered by time which do
you think is most comfortable
to list the months this way up and down
or
oops list the months this way across the
bottom from left to right what do you
reckon
of course generally we're like oh
passage of time from left to right
okay so if you've got a chronological
one then usually we have vertical bars
if you've got that kind of data i mean
you don't have to but just looks weird
if um if you have january february march
etc
okay so that's the first one secondly if
you have some kind of
ranked data
so for our example you might say okay
i've got my different classes
and i'm comparing which one had the
highest average mark or something like
that
okay because your ranking thing you're
putting them from like first to last
instead of arranging them vertically
right we usually have
horizontal bars so you're like okay the
longest one the best class we put up
here
and then the second best and all the way
down that's just the way we tend to view
ranks
so i'm going to say horizontal bars
now this is just usually there's no
rules that say oh you have to do it this
way
we're just trying to communicate as
clearly as we can and this kind of just
feels natural
so those are the two important
categories when you look at one that's
like
kind of neither here nor there you
really can put it
any way you like and you you'll have to
read them both ways
which way would you like me to do this
vertical bars or horizontal ones
vertical okay now i think vertical's
pretty pretty common
when you have these numbers over here
you're like oh i think i'm comparing
them up and down
that kind of thing so let's go with
across the bottom
i'm going to have my beef rice eggs fish
etc okay so let's do that
i've got five things there so it's nice
to make these kinds of things evenly
spaced so i'm going to
mark them out
okay now by
common bar graphs they tend to have gaps
between the um
uh between the bars i'll let you have a
think for a second as to why that's
usually the convention it's not always
but usually
so i'm going to label each of these
according to the food
that it is okay so i've got beef
rice and so on
okay so i've got them all set up
now i will before i leave off i've
got this bottom axis sort of all marked
out but i want to say what this thing is
right so i'm going to put an
overarching label over the entire thing
and that leaves this vertical axis i now
have to measure now
you can see my highest value is going to
be 35 okay so that's how high up i need
to go
i kind of need to decide how high i need
to go but also a scale
like how frequently should i mark it out
it's probably a bit overkill to have
35 individual marks so what do you think
would be like a reasonable amount
every how many to put up five
seven um seven i think five and seven
would both
work because i will point out you've got
um i mean
five times seven is 35 you've got um
uh a 13 which is very close to 14.
i think though fives are a lot easier to
count in um it's going to be closer to
like these guys
so i think five's kind of like fives
tens they're easy options to go for
okay so that means if we're going to go
up to 35 you'll need
seven markings so make sure you're
evenly spacing them
excuse me all right
now the way i tend to like to do it is
once you've got these numbers in here
we chose them every five so i'm going to
mark in what they are
5 10 etc
don't forget just like the horizontal
axis down here the vertical
axis is worth marking in and it actually
has two pieces of information worth
putting on there
what it is but also what units it's
involved in okay so that might be
percent
or degrees or mills or a mark whatever
it is
include it so i'm going to pop it in
over here
done so the last thing is actually to
put in the data okay
so i'm going to mark out where each of
these are and then i'm going to do all
of my vertical lines together
so beef comes all the way up to 35 so
just make sure you're
reading across your graph properly and
i'm going to the wrong mark so i'm going
to go
on okay so as you're completing that
i'm now going to pose the question back
to you because there is a
reasonable answer for it a conventional
answer why do you think it is
this is a column or bar graph okay um
something which we're going to have a
look at next week
very closely related slightly different
is something called a
histogram now when you have a look at a
histogram
one of the things you'll notice about it
is that histograms are
not like this they don't generally have
gaps so i want you to have a look at
this
why do you think it might be clearer it
might make more sense
to have our bars actually separated from
each other and
not touching yeah give any suggestions
okay so the first thing is just to make
it like easier to read it's like
especially if these were like colored in
solid it's super obvious so that's the
first thing
yeah another suggestion because they're
not to show a pattern
they're more like they're showing that
following thing
yeah sure so obviously these are all
these are all foods right
but it's not like oh i transitioned from
beef to rice and then from rice to eggs
like these things
are genuinely separate things and
they're not like interconnected like
remember when i talked about like months
of the year
they're interconnected they flow onto
each other do you want to give another
suggestion sooner
or a question is it wrong if you did
them or joined up
um okay so the short answer is
no because like just think okay i said
this before when we started done with
statistics
the rules here are there are no rules
right it's just like in english
when we talk about like rules in the
english language it's like there are no
rules we break them all the time okay
it's just about do you communicate
clearly okay now
here the convention is we separate them
out because number one
it is a bit clearer and number two it
communicates that these are separate
things okay and they're not actually
connected to each other if you put them
together
you'll sometimes even see a graph and
they're connected and you're like
what's with that okay you can still read
it though um i'm just pointing out i
think it's better
it's better to when you see one of these
keep them separate
i'll explain later on when we get to
them properly when would you do a
histogram why would it be useful
like remember i said these are more
useful than a standard leaf plot if all
you want is like the overall pattern
well there's a reason for these two um
if you've drawn your thing now
and there are no gaps then just leave it
it's okay but um like i said
i think the the best way to approach it
is to maybe you want to put a note for
yourself
but these have gaps
okay